The world is headed for stagflation next
year.
That's according to the latest Bloomberg
survey of professional and retail
investors.
What's stagflation, anyway?
It's a scenario when inflation remains
above average.
Even as growth slows, that would be a
nightmare for the Federal Reserve and
other central banks that have spent most
of this year deploying jumbo rate hikes
to rein in inflation.
In a stagflation scenario, that would
mean that those rate hikes will have
been ineffective in curbing prices, even
as economic demand slows.
About a third of investors are even more
downbeat and expect a deflationary
recession, which means that both
economic output and prices fall.
Meanwhile, they see plenty of risks in
housing markets.
Most investors expect a 20 percent
plunge in house prices in a major
economy globally, with Canada and the
U.K.
seen as the most vulnerable to this risk
overall.
One thing's for sure 2023 is a year for
the pessimists.